good morning everybody seven o'clock
here in the uk very welcome to spend
your breakfast with us here at sky news
gp's under pressure and now plan to name
and shame those not doing enough to
deliver face-to-face appointments the
health secretary study javid on the show
shortly to explain his thinking plus can
other countries trust doing trade deals
with the uk
after the eu offers an olive branch on
the deal we signed on the northern
ireland protocol
we'll put that to the shadow foreign
secretary emily thornbury actually she's
with us as well
[Music]
leave me aboard energize energize
[Music]
yeah beam me up bezos why spaceships
like william shatner's voyage to the
stars haven't had the royal seal of
approval we'll be discussing that with
the astronaut tim peake at half past
nine and
half term heaven oh yeah we'll take you
on a little holiday to some of those
countries that have come off the red
list
we're going to are you ready bali and
abu dhabi half past seven i know we're
spoiling you thursday 14th of october
name and shame league tables for gps to
boost face-to-face appointments but
those who don't deliver won't get a
slice of the new nhs pie
you should always be able to see a gp
not over telephone
not by video you should be able to have
a gp's appointment within at least 24
hours
i'm in a gp surgery in west london where
doctors are under pressure to see more
patients despite doing longer hours
without enough staff
bow and arrow attacks five people shot
dead and two wounded in norway as police
charge a suspect
we can't fix every problem as warnings
continue of a christmas supply crisis
the chancellor appears to rule out
helping businesses with soaring gas
prices
we're doing absolutely everything we can
to mitigate some of these challenges
they are global in nature so we can't
fix every single problem
uk and eu officials to meet after an
offer to cut 80 per cent of checks on
some goods moving from great britain to
northern ireland but will that be
accepted
caribbean climate grenada calls for more
foreign aid to help combat the crippling
cost of climate change ahead of the cop
26 summit our special report at half
past eight on this island alone that's
going to cost hundreds of millions of
dollars that's way more than it can
afford and it's a story that's playing
out on climate vulnerable nations across
the world
as lava continues to burn buildings on
la palma we'll talk to a volcanologist
on mount etna about the island's future
[Music]
good morning to you gps under pressure
to provide more face-to-face
appointments are to be put into league
tables with those not giving an
appropriate level of appointments uh not
given access to a new slice of nhs
funding a doctor has told this program
this morning that gps feel bashed by the
government and that there simply aren't
enough doctors around sky news data
shows a big fall in the number of gps in
large parts of england over the last
five years
special analysis by skye's data team has
found northern parts of the country have
been particularly hard hit with the area
of blackburn with darwin seeing its
numbers fall
from 45 gps per 100 000 patients to 33 a
27 drop
face-to-face appointments are still
below pre-pandemic levels across england
in the same area just 35.9 percent of
appointments were face to face this
summer compared with the 87.8 percent in
2019. instagram rasheed reports now from
blackman with darwin where gps and their
patients are calling for more funding
access to a gp is the first line of much
needed care for julie
two years ago she developed sepsis today
she struggles to see a doctor face to
face that should be your first point to
call your gp and you should be able to
see a gp no matter what you should
always be able to see a gp
not over telephone
not by video you should be able to have
a gp's appointment within at least 24
hours
it doesn't help that she lives in the
area which was losing gps even before
the pandemic
now the frustrations are too much well
you just feel so low you just sometimes
i just feel like crying out for help and
there's just nobody there it's just gone
to dogs especially that's that's the way
the health service has just gone through
the dogs
after years of cuts to budgets and a
waning number of colleagues gps across
the country are in crisis
tell me about the ultrasound scan now
dr murthy has been doing this job for
more than 30 years he loves it but he
says being a gp in blackburn right now
is the most difficult it's ever been
i'm working at the moment almost 10
hours a day
including and i'm also working on the
weekends
just to catch up some urgent work not
the routine work
that is the reality of it we are seeing
40 50 patients either on telephone face
to face
and that is per day and by the time in
the evening you are exhausted
it's a situation public health leaders
here say is all too familiar
we lost a year's male life expectancy
during the covered pandemic we're never
going to recover
equal life chances for our children if
we don't
make sure that everyone has equal and
fair access to gps
but with a funding boost from government
signs of levelling up are now on show
they say access to gps will improve and
there will be an increase in
face-to-face appointments an extra 250
million pounds will alleviate this
national problem
without gps our nhs would crack and
crumble it's clear they need this help
now more than ever so they can help
those who need it insane rasheed sky
news blackburn
pleased to have the health secretary
with us this morning hello to you busy
day for you thanks for taking the time
to join us this morning tell us about
your plans to improve access to gps well
first i want to thank gps for the
phenomenal work that they've done
especially during the pandemic but of
course everything they continue to do
and we want to support them to do what
they do best which is to see patients
and to see more patients properly and in
a way that the the patient chooses and
that's what this gp access package is
about that we're now seeing today so it
includes action on multiple fronts to
achieve just that and you know for
example three of the major measures
inside this package is an extra 250
million pound of winter access fund that
will help increase capacity there's uh
also measures by the uk uh health
security agency and changes to the
social distancing guidance and then also
an expansion of what's called the
community pharmacy scheme and taken
together with all the other measures
this will help gps to see more people
face to face and more properly should
everyone who wants a face-to-face
appointment be able to have one yeah i
think patients i believe in choice so i
i think that's what patients want to see
and the vast majority of gps
i talk to they they say look if you can
help us to increase capacity if you can
provide support that's also what we want
to do so i think patients you should
have a choice and if those if there are
some that will absolutely choose that
they prefer remote or online versus
face-to-face and that absolutely can be
right for them but there should be a
choice um
they feel as though they're under
pressure though don't they feel like
they're being battered by the government
at the moment and they're doing
everything that they possibly can i
think gps are working incredibly hard
and especially over the last couple of
years i mean could there have been a
more testing time for anyone working in
healthcare it's hard to have imagined
that and and i think they have what
they've done especially around the
vaccination program for example has been
phenomenal but at the same time we we've
also seen an increase in the waiting
lists for the nhs more generally we've
seen people stay away from the nhs
including their gps for understandable
reasons uh during the pandemic and so we
do need to increase capacity and there
are many people that will you they want
to be seen in a certain way and i think
it's right that we support gps deliver
that yeah but gps are seeing people more
face to face now than they ever have
been aren't they
uh and i think the from what i've seen
the latest uh numbers that are published
by the nhs before the pandemic i think
it was roughly around 80 percent of
consultations were face-to-face at the
moment it's around
and
60 and and gene just looking at some
figures so i don't know if you recognize
these in the week beginning 16th of
august gps provided 5.6 million
appointments and gave 374 000 covered
jobs at jab's forgive me 2019 for the
equivalent week 5.3 million appointments
and no jabs and there are 1900 fewer gps
over that time so they're doing more
work now than they've ever done before
well you uh maybe the stats you relay is
total appointments rather than broken
down between sort of remote and
face-to-face but it's true certainly gps
are seeing more people including
vaccinations they've been an important
part of our vaccination program
especially for elderly people and going
to care homes in in many cases and
that's been really vital uh support in
terms of gp numbers which you just
touched on look we do have a shortage of
gps in this country and the the
government has recognized that over the
last two years we've actually seen an
increase in the full-time equivalent
number of gps of something like i think
1
200. so we have seen an increase but i i
want to see a lot more gp
fewer gps over that period of time over
the last two years there's been an
increase um depending on how far back
you go you can have difficulty in 2015
cameron was promising us every week at
the dispatch box there'd be 5 000 more
gps were there well i want to see more
gps and it will take time to get more
gps into the system this year i was 60
years ago well this summer this summer
we had the highest number of students
enter medical school for gp training and
that does mean you know we've got to
we're building that pipeline but look
we've been very clear about this i think
that we do need more clinicians
generally throughout the nhs whether
that's in primary care in acute care and
that is something that's happening
nurses you know we're hiring many more
nurses as well
and that support continues and that
continues with record funding into the
nhs
both over the pandemic and before that
with the long-term plan but today's
announcement is about gp access and it's
right that we provide more support
shouldn't we be enjoying them embracing
the tech thing i mean
embracing the technology you don't have
to be face to face quite often i
interview your colleagues down the line
doesn't mean that what they're saying is
any less effect less we should
absolutely be making maximum use of uh
technology throughout the nhs it's
something i've talked about very
recently actually how i want to see that
and what we have seen during the
pandemic is that people understand at
that time at the height of the pandemic
you could only be seen remotely everyone
understands that and there will be some
people that think maybe if they've done
that for the first time that suits them
they might have a busy life it might be
a minor illness and that might suit them
and that's that's a decision for them
but what i've also heard is from gps
directly is that we need more support
you need to cut away some of the
bureaucracy we face you need to give us
more funding so that we can perhaps work
overtime and open longer hours and
support us with that and you need to
speak to the ukhsa to see if they will
continue with their review of the nhs
and the infection control guidance and
which which you know which is what's
happened and so we've been listening
we've taken action
and i want to thank again gps for
everything that they're doing they will
continue to have the full support of the
government of the nhs in everything that
they do yeah are you listening though i
mean
um a survey from the bma you know giving
you figures again 50 of doctors
suffering from anxiety depression stress
or burnout
60 high levels of fatigue
30 taking up additional unpaid hours to
try to make sure they're there for their
patients when they're needed i was
speaking to a gp this morning who said
to me ask him who runs the nhs you or
the daily mail
well the nhs is run everyone knows how
the nhs is run through
a professional your serious management
we've just appointed you ceo of the nhs
and it's gps that will decide in their
particular surgery how they're going to
run that day-to-day but what they've
also done
but what they what they've also said is
that they need more support to to see
more patients differently they're
knackered they're depressed
and they feel that you're bashing them
well actually
there are there have actually been over
the last uh a few months i've certainly
noticed while i've been in this job
there have been some horrid cases of
abuse towards health workers to social
care workers to gps including that and i
have to say that is totally unacceptable
at any level there's a zero tolerance as
far as i'm concerned about abuse to
anyone
health and social care and what one one
of the reasons that gps have said to me
that they they feel pressured is because
of some of the abuse that they suffer it
might be online abuse it might be
anonymous and one of the things i've
included in this package as well is for
the first time a 5 million pound
security fund so for those gp surgeries
that feel that they want to take extra
measures on security there's support for
that as well and the final thing if i
may mention something else i do want to
do and i can't announce the full details
of it today because i want to work with
gps and the nhs more broadly and get it
right is
when i was a home secretary i i decided
i wanted to do something that became the
the police covenant to provide more
long-term support put it into law for
police in that case of course and i want
to do something very similar for all nhs
workers of course including our
fantastic gps and i want to work with
people and get that right to show
and also demonstrate and give more
support yeah they don't feel supported
they feel bashed by the government
that's that's my point they don't feel
that you that you've got their back well
this this whole package today is about
support the the funding that we're
putting in the extra 250 million a
quarter of a billion pounds of new fresh
funding is something that we've been
asked for and in fact many people from
the feedback i've got already have been
surprised by the size and the of the
financial support that's being provided
but the support we're providing through
working with a pharmacist so that they
can take some of that load off gps and
deal with some of the minor illnesses
the support we're providing and taking
away some of the red tape and this is
all support and it's all about helping
gps so they can do what they love best
which is seeing their patients but you
know you plan to name and shame those
who don't actually reach those targets
that you're going to put in front
whatsoever for that i mean that we what
we are doing is perception is reality
and this is what my this is what a gp
said to me this morning when i told him
that you were coming into the program
these are the points that he wanted me
to put and that and and that gp
obviously i don't know who that is but
entitled of course to their views but
it's also important that we stick to
facts and so what we are doing is uh
providing more data and more
transparency so these are people on the
front line and they don't understand the
facts is that what you're saying well
we've published a document today i don't
know if the the document was published
this morning at around 6am so i don't
know whether the the person that you're
referring to has had the time to read
the entire document which goes into the
number of pages and goes into immense
detail i mean has do you know if that
person read the document first i have no
idea well there you go so uh based on
the facts do you think that this
of these gps half of whom are suffering
from depression i think it's going to
help because this is about providing
more support
more financial support removing the red
tape that gps have often talked to me
about it's about spreading the workload
for for primary care for example using
the community pharmacy scheme more it's
provide support also there's a there's a
plan in there to provide direct support
to those uh practices that ask for it
that would like more expert advice and
and the nhs can send in a team and help
them with that and the point i just
wanted to make because you did touch on
it it's about transparency at the moment
when you get data at a gp level it's
only available at a regional level not
practiced by practice the nhs now for
well over a year has been
piloting the scheme i think with 60
practices where it's practiced by
practice data and this is important it's
important that patients have this
information because i also want to see a
leveling up of healthcare throughout the
country i've talked a lot about
disparities in healthcare and i think we
do need to understand what the
differences in healthcare provision are
across the country and have the best
data available okay you talked about
transparency there did we ever intend to
stick to the protocol when it um came to
the brexit agreement over northern
ireland because of course you'll know mr
cummings has said we signed the deal
never planning to stick to it and to
ditch the bits we didn't like further
down the line we signed that agreement
in good faith i was in the in the
government then in a different role and
i know we signed it in good faith and uh
of course it's been two years roughly
since then and it's right that we look
at how it's working we don't think it's
working well in practice
we think for example the eu is taking in
an over-legalistic approach and i think
it's right that we talk to our friends
in the eu again and see if any changes
can be made so what they've said is as
you know because i'm sure you've read it
um they're basically budging on 80
of the uh the options for uh amongst
other things sausage wars as it's been
described but one thing they've even
moved a little bit as far as what the
european court of justice is concerned
and whether they will be overseeing um
the change in rules is that going to be
enough i i haven't seen the eu document
yet i haven't had any time to to study
it it's good that they're engaging with
this discussion i know for example from
the area that i'm responsible for your
medicines healthcare more broadly that
we've had issues with medicine supply in
northern ireland and no one wants to see
issues like that it's not in anyone's
interest whether they're in northern
ireland or ireland for that matter and i
think it's important that these
discussions continue and if sensible
changes can be made that's exactly what
we'd want to see is the european court
of justice a red line for the government
i think we do we there's no really
looking forward there should not be a
role for the european court of justice
in in anywhere any part of the uk and
that includes northern ireland i think
it's a an over-legalistic approach that
the court has so they've got the sticky
fingers anywhere near it we're not it's
not a deal and it's and i think lord
frost has been really clear about this
with the speech that he made this week
and and what he said i think are the the
principal uh arguments and one of those
issues one of the most important issues
is to end the role of the ecj in
northern ireland and i think that's one
of the the better ways to make sure that
we're also protecting what was agreed in
the good friday agreement for the
benefit of not just everyone in northern
ireland but an island too the whole
island of ireland yes safety and
security in northern ireland of course
but it does sound as though we're going
to reject it from what you're saying
look that's not a decision
for me and uh i'm focused on health
matters you've asked me about the
protocol i've shared my views but you're
representing the government this morning
i know it's something that uh lord frost
will look at very carefully and if the
government decides to to take a a
different approach
then it will be a collective decision
okay just a quick thought before i let
you go i read in the paper this morning
that your mum had always wanted you to
be a doctor
um i'm guessing she might want you to be
a lorry driver at the moment we're in
short supply
well i think the government's addressing
that issue there's a sort of supply of
lorry drivers across the world and i
think there's a shortage of four hundred
thousand roughly in europe and some
seven i don't know why they don't wanna
come here we wanted five 5020 so far i
think being a lawyer is a great job uh
by the way and so uh i hope that you
managed to get that in just under the
wire through our lower drivers this
morning
i hope that more people are attracted to
that why do you think they're not
i think there's multiple issues it's got
to
we're seeing this issue across
europe across actually recently in the
us as well there's a shortage and uh it
and it's i think a lot of it has to do
with the pandemic and the sudden demand
that's been created as the world's in
effect sort of waking up
after the economic shock and it will
take some time to sort this out in terms
of what we've done in the uk to attract
more people into the industry that's
going to help and and i'm sure that you
know this will be something that will be
resolved in the months to come okay i
have to let you go i know there's so
many other people that you're going to
talk to but when um
our previous health secretary matt
hancock came and did a 45 minute ask the
health secretary will you come and do
the same for us as long as it's with you
of course how can we go can somebody
make sure that we've got a note of that
thanks a lot that's great thanks so much
indeed thank you let's bring in our
correspondent molina who's standing by
at a gp surgery in west london for us
this morning melania i wonder how
they'll be feeling about what they've
heard from their boss today
well quite mixed feelings kay there are
some measures that are welcome such as
reducing bureaucracy in red tape
bringing other health professionals to
do things like fit for work notes and
provide checks for the dvla that has
been broadly welcomed but gps are
warning that those are measures that are
going to take some time to implement so
it's not going to be a quick fix
it's not like immediately there'll be a
man's capacity for more appointments and
gps are also saying that this measure
that patients can now rate their
surgeries can be really demoralizing for
a workforce that's already pretty much
on their knees after a long pandemic gps
are saying there are already ways that
you can feed back your experience and
this could be just another blow to an
already suffering profession and then
struggling practices could be penalized
instead of being supported another thing
that the royal college of gps are saying
is that they simply don't have enough
staff their workforce is overstretched
they need more many more thousands of
gps and they want the government to
support them in that way
okay thank you malena thank you
gonna be talking to a gp later on in the
programme still to come this hour 7 30
we'll be visiting some dream
destinations abu dhabi and bali looking
to open their doors to international
travel in time for half term have you
booked
yet 20-8 talking to the welsh first
minister ahead of the queen's opening of
the sixth session of the senate
quarter eight be joined by the director
of the northern ireland retail
consortium aidan connolly to discuss
what next the northern ireland protocol
[Music]
before that norwegian police have
charged a 37 year old danish man after
five people were killed with a bow and
arrow in the town of conksburg
two more were injured in the attack
which happened 50 miles southwest of the
capital oslo police were called to the
center of kongsberg at 6 30 last night
with reinforcements quickly sent in from
other areas joining us now from
congressburg is tv 2 reporter theo
odengarden hello tithia thanks for
joining us tell us more about what
happened
hello good morning so we just got the
news about the man who did this attack
and that he acknowledges the conditions
so he hasn't played guilty but he
confirms that
he is the man who did these terrible
actions last night we know a bit more
about this man now he's as you said a 37
year year old danish citizen who lives
in kongsberg and he has
been here last night been shooting
around with this bow and arrow police
confirmed now that he also used other
weapons which is nice
and it was half an hour with chaos here
in kongsberg he was just
moving around town in the center and
shooting at people and yeah people were
running for their lives and it was a bit
scary and confusing the whole situation
do we actually know what the motive was
i mean do we actually have any further
details oh i think we might have lost
thea are you still there there no she
isn't unfortunately
you can hear me okay we can still hi
motives what are the motives
yeah we don't know about the motives
then the police say um that it's a bit
early to say something about it but they
say now that they cannot um
they have to consider this as a terror
uh
terror
thing because
um
they don't know the motives uh and and
it's uh when so many people are killed
it's uh naturally to to see that uh
perspective too
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
the update really appreciate it thank
you
thank you thanks
chancellor rishi sunak says the
government is doing everything it can to
improve the situation in the face of the
supply chain crisis affecting countries
around the world the shipping giant musk
says it's diverting vessels away from
felix stone the uk's largest container
port because of a buildup of cargo the
plan is to unload elsewhere and use
smaller vessels to get deliveries to the
uk
that's going to take time isn't it
what's clear is that many countries
around the world are experiencing supply
chain challenges just like we're seeing
in the uk we're doing absolutely
everything we can to mitigate some of
these challenges they are global in
nature so we can't fix every single
problem but i feel confident that there
will be good provision of goods for
everybody and we are working our way to
remove blockages where we can
similar situation at los angeles where
container ships can be seen sitting in
the bay there traffic jam that's
threatening the us economy joe biden has
promised to expand operations but it's
the holiday shopping that's worrying
people
the port of los angeles announced today
that it's going to be begin operating 24
hours a day seven days a week this is
the first key step toward moving our
entire freight transportation and
logistical supply chain nationwide to a
24 7 system
let's have a quick look at some of the
papers for you this morning now the
express says shoppers are being urged to
buy their christmas presents early
because of the supply chain crisis the
mirror calls it the rush to save
christmas
and it's also the lead story for the eye
which says shops are facing goods delays
for christmas the mail reports on a raft
of new funding to be offered to gps
across the country in an effort to get
them to see more patients face to face
and the metro carries prince william's
criticism of space tourism of the sort
enjoyed by william shatner he insists
the future of the planet should be a
bigger priority
many women are being forced to take time
off work and even leave their jobs
because of a lack of support during the
menopause that's according to a poll of
just under 4 000 women which found that
most feel the menopause or the time
leading up to it had a major impact on
their lives and careers as aisha zahid
reports
at 43 katie began experiencing
debilitating symptoms brought on by the
menopause from anxiety to insomnia
working life became a struggle
it was really significant because i was
existing on about three hours sleep a
night you know it's very common a lot of
women suffer with insomnia um and i was
dragging myself into the office
i couldn't concentrate because i was so
exhausted the brain fog you know really
impacted on you know my own ability to
do my job
over the course of several years she had
to leave three jobs
it's the embarrassment around the taboo
of
not wanting to tell your bosses what
you're going through you're worried that
they're going to think they should never
have employed you um or that you know
you're not really fit for purpose so
i i stopped work and it was really
pretty upsetting
katie isn't alone according to new
research 99 of women say their symptoms
have negatively affected their careers
more than half have had to take time off
work and 60 say their workplace didn't
offer any menopause support
professionals are calling on employers
to do more they want to see menopause
treated in the same way as mental health
and maternity
schemes menopause has such a negative
impact for so many women and these women
aren't receiving the right health
support and treatment but their only
option is to not go for promotion to
reduce their hours or to give up work
which is so sad it's a personal loss for
them but it's also a loss for the
economy as well and organizations are
hemorrhaging women
katie has made it her goal to raise
awareness around the menopause but
starting conversation is just the
beginning
ultimately change lies in the hands of
employers aisha zahid sky news
in la palma there's no sign that the
volcanic activity will end soon as a new
stream of lava escaped from the erupting
volcano hundreds of people in spain's
canary islands feared for their homes
and property as a new river of lava
threatened to destroy their
neighborhoods all they could do was
watch
and hope torrents of molten rock have
destroyed well over a thousand buildings
in the three weeks since the eruption
according to the canary islands volcanic
institute
these are live pictures right now
my goodness me it continues to do its
worst on the island of la palma and it
doesn't look as though it's going to
subside anytime soon speaking to an
expert a volcanologist
in the next hour here on scotties
[Music]
prince william has hit out at the space
tourism industry just hours after the
star trek uh captain cook william
shatner touched down after his 11-minute
voyage to the edge of space williams
said it was time to focus the world's
greatest minds on trying to fix the
earth instead of trying to find the next
place to go and live
beam me up scotty williams commons came
even as the 90 year old actor was
experiencing weightlessness and seeing
the earth from a perspective most people
will never see his trip was made
possible by the billionaire owner of
amazon and the space rocket jeff bezos
90 years old
goodness me
glad we got those star trek pictures on
after an exhilarating trip to outer
space william shatner was visibly
emotional and thanked the team for
making it possible
here's what he had to say
you have given me
is the most profound experience
i can announce
i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i i just
it's extraordinary
9 30 we are going to be joined by the
british astronaut tim peake
to talk through william shatner's
journey and also probably uh prince
william's reaction as well looking
forward to that
they say two heads are better than one
but i'm not quite sure this is what they
had in mind have a look at these
pictures a jewel headed terrapin
is the newest attraction at an american
wildlife center
in cape
cod
it's claimed the unnamed turtle has
now i don't know how to pronounce this
somebody probably does bicephaly i think
a condition granting two heads due to a
rare environmental factors uh during an
embryo's development vets found it at a
protected nesting site before being
taken to hospital for assessment the
findings suggest its right side of the
body is more developed than the left but
can still eat and also digest food and
it's also got
six legs
uh looking at our climate dashboard for
you here we go um as i always say um
it can be a little bit overwhelming but
please don't let it be i'll break it
down for you top row there you are
that's the real time power mix so for
example it says fossil fuels there 36
that was 50 odd percent earlier on in
the week so we're not as reliant on
fossil fuels towards the end of the week
much more from uh renewables and the one
below that 1.23 degrees higher now than
it was in 1880 when records began
uh when it gets to one and a half
degrees celsius higher than 1880 that's
when scientists are very anxious indeed
and they're telling us as of today
that's 11 years away unless we do
something about it very much on the
agenda at cop 26
at the beginning of next month as is the
total carbon dioxide emissions at the
bottom there in millions of tons watch
that clicking through and a reminder
that you can get all the latest on the
sky news daily climate show which airs
every weekday evening at 6 30.
uh we were hearing from the health
secretary just a short time ago and he
was talking amongst other things about
gps new packages for gps hundreds of
millions of pounds will it be enough i
was chatting to a gp this morning and he
said ask him who's running the nhs is it
him or is it the daily mail
we've taken action and i want to thank
again gps for everything that they're
doing they will continue to have the
full support of the government of the
nhs in everything that they do yeah are
you listening though i mean
um a survey from the bma you know giving
you figures again 50 of doctors
suffering from anxiety depression stress
or burnout
60 high levels of fatigue
30 taking up additional unpaid hours to
try to make sure they're there for their
patients when they're needed i was
speaking to a gp this morning who said
to me
ask him who runs the nhs you or the
daily mail
well the nhs is run everyone knows how
the nhs is run through
a professional your serious management
we've just appointed you ceo of the nhs
and its gps that will decide in their
particular surgery how they're going to
run that day to day
i've also asked him about the northern
ireland protocol sausage walls basically
and whether the um the europeans who've
bent over backwards they would say um
taking away 80
of the regulations that are in place at
the moment would that be enough
for the uk to finally agree that deal
looking forward there should not be a
role for the european court of justice
in in anywhere any part of the uk and
that includes northern ireland i think
it's uh an over legalistic approach that
the court has they've got the sticky
fingers anywhere near it we're not it's
not a deal and it's and i think lord
frost has been really clear about this
with the speech that he made uh this
week and and and what he said i think of
the the principle uh arguments and and
one of those issues one of the most
important issues is to end the role of
the ecj in northern ireland and i think
that's one of the the better ways to
make sure that we're also protecting
what was agreed in the good friday
agreement for the benefit of not just
everyone in northern ireland but an
island too the whole island of ireland
tamara's here thoughts tomorrow good
morning morning um so sajid javid is
alive to these concerns we've got
newspaper campaigns about the lack of
face-to-face gp appointments obviously
during the pandemic a lot of that had to
go on to phone calls and to video calls
and while some people are perfectly
happy with that he said that gps should
be able to decide themselves whether
someone wants to have a video call wants
to be seen in person but if someone does
want to be seen in person they should be
able to see them and he accepts that
means more resources this 250 million a
lot of that is going to go on locums
which will increase the number of
appointments so that is good especially
because in some areas as we just heard
there are up to 3 000 patients being
seen by just one gp so that will help
but these are not people who know the
patient so it doesn't help with what he
admitted is a long-term issue of
training up more gps and retaining them
because so many are leaving the
profession due to burnout so it does go
some way to solve the issues raised by
the pandemic
and hopefully he he says people will be
able to see their gps in larger numbers
because we've only got just under 60
percent of consultations now happening
in person versus eighty percent before
the pandemic so it will go some way to
solving those issues and also we've got
the social distancing guidelines
changing today which he hopes will
encourage more gps to see patients in
person yeah but did he acknowledge that
tech meant that you don't necessarily
have to be in the surgery to see a gp
and not everybody wants that yes he said
that he wants to see increased use of
tech across the nhs and that there will
be a lot of people with minor conditions
young people busy people who are quite
happy to have a video call but a lot of
the concern is focused on people who
feel that they want to see their gp and
have been unable to and i think he is
alive to those to those concerns and
this will he didn't i thought was
interesting
say i want it to go back to pre-pandemic
80 of consultations in person it may be
that we never go back to that okay for
now thanks very much tomorrow's take
nine o'clock looking forward to it now
the queen is to attend the ceremonial
opening of the sixth session of the
welsh centered her first without prince
philip but with the introduction of
mandatory coveted passes in wales plus
the military being brought in to help
the ambulance services meet demand the
first ministers warned that coronavirus
restrictions will continue into next
year pleased to say that he's with us
now mark drakeford of course hello to mr
drake but thanks for joining us on the
programme i'm sure you're thrilled to be
meeting her majesty again this morning
yes of course it's a huge pleasure to
have the queen opening the senate for
the sixth time she's been here every
time since 1999
and we look forward to welcoming her
again today
why is it so important to
for this to happen in the presence of
her majesty
well because it marks the significance
of the parliament here
in wales with a devolved system here in
the united kingdom decisions are made in
four different parliaments and i know
the queen has always
taken very seriously
the job that she does in marking that as
i say she's never missed an opening of a
new senev term
and despite the circumstances
and her age she will be making that
effort again today
talk to me if you would about what's
going on with the ambulance service if i
could just slightly move away obviously
it's an area that is must be of some
significant concern for you at the
moment you don't have enough paramedics
the ambulance service is under enormous
pressure the numbers of people needing
the ambulance service is growing but it
still has to operate under covered
conditions so that its ability to get
back on the road and to see as many
people as it did previously is still
affected by needing to put on ppe to
observe cleaning of ambulances between
calls and so on
we've been able to secure some
assistance from the armed forces we're
really grateful for that we've had it
throughout the pandemic they won't be
responding to emergency calls but they
will be helping with some of the more
routine work that the ambulance service
does freeing up trained ambulance
personnel to deal with the most urgent
work that the service has to provide
talk to me if you would please about um
sausage wars northern ireland protocol a
lot of
freight will be going from your country
of course over to
northern ireland we've heard again from
the government this morning certainly
the europeans appear to have been
bending over backwards to try to get
this sorted out but we heard from the
health secretary that
as long as the european court of justice
is still involved then
it doesn't look as though it will
necessarily get over the line what are
your thoughts on that
well it is certainly a very important
issue for wales because our ports face
the island of ireland and trade through
our ports is significantly down
following uh brexit now i am frankly
baffled by some of the things we hear by
from the uk government
uh the deal is the deal that they
themselves signed up to it is their deal
yet so often we hear you uk government
ministers talk as though the deal was
entirely somebody else's responsibility
now i met the eu ambassador to the
united kingdom yesterday i agree that
the announcements they make do genuinely
show practical attempts to deal with the
problems they've been at the border
i don't think it's helpful when uk
ministers uh make hardline speeches
drawing red lines
criticizing the deal that they
themselves had signed
so from a welsh point of view what we've
always asked for
is for people to be around the table for
people to be pragmatic for people to be
looking for where they can agree
rather than constantly setting out red
lines about where they are not prepared
to agree
um whatever you think of uh dominic
cummings he was the man in the room he
was the man that was brought in to get
this deal over the line and he has said
again today yesterday he's doubled down
and said uh we never planned to stick by
it obviously we only wanted the bits
that we wanted what would you say in
response to that
well a country that behaves in that way
will never find partners in the rest of
the world
prepared to do serious business with
them
when the uk
puts its name to a treaty with other
parts of the world
then it's absolutely incumbent on us
to act in good faith with that agreement
and the deep cynicism of the thought
that you heard for mr cummings does real
damage to the reputation of the united
kingdom and our ability in a post
post-brexit world
to strike agreements with countries
elsewhere
okay um
busy day and important day for you so we
must let you go thank you for joining us
you thank you
now half terms approaching and there are
places around the world who'd love to
welcome back visitors after so long
locked down by coronavares
let's dare to dream should we joined by
the general manager of the four seasons
resort in bali uday rayo hello to you
good morning from boston
oh my goodness look how fabulous it
looks behind you tell me why i should
come to your hotel
why there's uh many many reasons firstly
bali is uh super safe uh the
covet cases are reducing by the day the
vaccination rates uh on the island are
close to 65 percent
so
it's it's never been more safe
and the balinese couldn't be more
excited to have everybody back on the
island i think 18 months has been
far too long waiting for everybody to
come back but this is great uh there's
light at the end of the tunnel but the
two resorts are uh
are ready we are waiting for guests
we've introduced
many new experiences the
smiles of the balinese still remain the
care the warmth
of the balinese staff are
as everybody remembers bali to be
we have brand new
spa which we just completed last year we
have
wonderful new experiences
both at both properties
so we're super excited to have everybody
back
i have to say i have to say uday you had
me at hello to be fair um tell me about
what we're looking at behind you
so
i'm actually at one of the properties
which is called the jimbaran bay i'm at
the four seasons in jimbaran which is
located
right on the beach so what you see is
the bay behind me
with
two kilometers of white sandy beaches
and
directly behind me is our main pool
oh
i believe that the bali authorities are
saying that you want to have more uh
families come and you want families to
come
and stay for longer um is that is that
your understanding no absolutely because
you know for the last 18 months
travelers families haven't been
traveling at all they couldn't go
they're cooped up in their
houses their apartments
children haven't been able to go out
at all so this is a perfect opportunity
for
families to come and get away and be out
in the open
and get on the beach
go into the pool
just relax and be together i
think i i see more and more of that
trend happening in the immediate future
so we're yeah waiting waiting for many
families to come
fantastic and and just tell me what the
temperatures might be doing on october
half term out of interest asking for a
friend
so it's the tropics so you're looking at
about uh high 28 uh 29 degrees
with uh blue skies and uh yeah plenty of
sunshine
yeah all right
it's fantastic and it looks so lovely
behind you thank you so much for
inviting me
we really appreciate it for both four
seasons thank you very much lovely thank
you for joining us thanks very much
indeed
okay now if it's not your kind of
holiday we've got something else we can
take you to abu dhabi huda al hossani is
a guy from tours by locals in abu dhabi
hello to you
hi hello hello tell me about city breaks
why is city breaks a good idea for half
term
um actually you all have like nice
beaches nice places to visit and even
nice architectures to see to see as what
you see behind me we have it's hat
towers and emirate palace hotels one of
the luxuries hotels in abu dhabi and um
with the with the with the crisis of the
copied and things we are like the six
countries who's handling the the most of
the things here so it's totally safe
uh the cases of the kovit is very low
like as low as you can imagine from the
first time we handled with this uh
cases so the people who think abu dhabi
or the city they will have a nice time
to uh
to experience a lot of things in the
capital of the united arab emirates
now what would you say to british women
who say
um
how do i know that i'm going to get a
warm reception if i travel to a middle
eastern country
actually we are welcoming all the
peoples or we have like a good
hospitalities for any
people who's coming from any anywhere
and i don't know if you hear about that
in dubai we have the expo 2020 start
from the first of october so we are
welcoming the people from uh like long
time ago by starting uh
having the people in to dubai and abu
dhabi is the capital so most of the
people they are curious to know about it
because not that much of people visit it
so let's have an area that the kids
can't go like they have a theme park
they have a nice beaches they have a
hood nice hotels and no at the end you
will be in very safe country also like
you can walking in the middle of the
night you can walking in the at the
evening of the at the daytime anytime a
day you can walking outside of the
street and you will be safe and enjoying
the lovely view of the city
fabulous what's the weather doing
okay nowadays the october is like the
best time to visit the country you can
at the daytime it will be between 33 to
30 degrees celsius and at the night it
will be between 28 to 25 degrees uh
sleazy but the weather to become became
more uh colder well since now till uh
january
sounds absolutely like the best time to
visit amazing amazing thank you so much
for taking the time to tell us a little
bit more about abu dhabi thank you
you're welcome thanks a lot
so another couple of places that you uh
might fancy we've taken you to goad
didn't we we took you to south africa
the wine lands
we took you to bali and now we've taken
you to abu dhabi this week who knows
where we might take you tomorrow looking
ahead to october half term now that so
few countries are left on the red list
is this the time for you to start
traveling again if you've got a
particular area that you'd like to go to
and you want to maybe have a snapshot of
it here on sky news why don't you send
me a quick tweet at k burley and i'll
see what our producers can do for you
now we've been discussing the european
union officials haven't we this morning
they're in london to begin intensive
talks on the proposed changes to the
northern ireland protocol northern
ireland also a fabulous place to go
european uh commission vice president
maris seferovic said the measures could
halve customs paperwork and cut checks
on meat dairy and other food products
coming to northern ireland from mainland
britain by 80 per cent the plan would
also ensure the free flow of medicines
but the oversight of the ecj would
remain something the health secretary
just told us in a major sticking point
joining us aiden connolly the director
of the northern ireland retail
consortium hello thanks for joining us
on the on the program this morning um
aiden we did hear that the european
court of justice overseeing the northern
ireland protocol is a big problem for
the british government although we have
seen quite a lot of concessions by the
european union is one reading of it
what's yours
um well as far as the european court of
justice jurisdiction i think it's easy
to say that uh for retailers we're more
and uh we're more concerned with uh
containers than courts and making sure
that there's a free flow of goods on the
face of it what's in the
european papers is quite good um what
the business community not just
retailers but the business community as
a whole northern ireland has been asking
for uh since the end of the transition
period is a way to remove friction we're
talking about 80 percent of of checks
going on 50 of of customers paperwork so
that is a a really good thing now the
devil is going to be in the detail and
we're going to have to run uh some
modeling because quite frankly it's not
a homogenous retail industry there's
lots of retail sectors within the retail
industry and we're going to have to find
out how that works
for our members but on the face of it
this is good news the only thing to say
same thing we said whenever the uk
command paper came out a solution is
only a solution if it can be uh agreed
with both sides and that means that both
sides need to sign up to whatever they
agree and this needs to happen before
christmas
what did you make of what we were
hearing from um dominic cummings that
the government was never going to honor
the agreement
well i i think dominic cummings is more
than entitled to his own opinion and i
think though we are more uh concerned
with the government as it is now we're
more concerned with the european union
and the relationship that we have with
the european union as it is now and
quite frankly a lot of this stuff
a is a huge distraction when business
wants to look at pragmatic solutions we
want to look for those four tests that
we have which is stability certainty
simplicity removing those frictions and
lastly and most importantly
affordability that keeps businesses
competitive and also keeps costs down
for northern ireland consumers because
quite frankly we have half of the
discretionary income of great british
households and that means that we can't
afford the cost rises that come with
friction and red tape
do you feel that you are edging closer
towards sorting out this sausage wars
issue
well i think the sausage was a complete
misnomer if people think that this was a
trade war over sausages that you know
this wasn't even the us a trade handbags
at dawn um i think we are closer i i
definitely think even if you look at
where we were in may and both sides uh
weren't
for moving and and and leaps and bounds
and that's what they have done however
nothing's agreed until it's all agreed
there's a lot of of work to do we're
gratified to say that uh some of the
proposals that were in the eu for
non-papers actually came from the
northern ireland business community we
do know that there are red lines we do
know that there is much negotiation that
still needs to happen what we can say
for certainty is that the northern
ireland business community and
especially northern ireland retailers
are more than willing to work with both
sides to get a long-term viable solution
that works not only for business but for
northern ireland households it's great
to talk to you thanks for taking the
time
thank you
thanks a lot
i'm just very keen to show you this a
new project aims to get a better idea of
the number of walruses on earth by
counting them
but from space
thousands of satellite images like these
are being searched online by volunteers
to see how many walruses they can spot
it doesn't look easy does it this area
on the bottom
well there that was their target that's
what they're looking for wallace is like
these scientists need improved
population data as they try to assess
how
the polar species will be affected by
climate change as walruses are heavily
dependent on sea ice you didn't know
that did you which has been melting
rapidly
i don't know that happy about it does he
you didn't know that every day is a
school day here on the breakfast show on
sky news still to come in the next hour
what does the health secretary think
about his gps and more importantly what
do they think about him stay tuned for
more